[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
nervous yeah it's been a long time
coming actually my name is Rhett but I
am nervous just a quick recap we've been
this week you don't got it straight I'm
off my game and I'm gonna be off my game
all day today this week and through this
week at the roundtable of them lighting
I am telling my story of how I kind of
got to where I am in terms of my belief
and why I don't believe what I used to
believe and of course this is all in a
larger series that we're doing the last
two podcasts we call the Lost years
where we covered you know all those
stories filling in the gaps of how we
got from being engineers to being
youtubers and the the path that we took
which was a little atypical involved
being missionaries for for a while yeah
if you haven't listened to those
previous two podcast I recommend
listening to those first but this one
and the next one are going to be totally
different in the previous two because
they're going to be very personal in
nature very singular in nature this is
your episode in the next week will be my
episode but can I just acknowledge the
conversation that's happened it's
happening oh I got you got a pic I got a
link usually doesn't do the timer and so
he doesn't know I system so I turn the
Wi-Fi off you just turn the
notifications off just want to
acknowledge how so many of you have
joined in the conversation using hashtag
your biscuits just letting us know how
you're processing our process it's been
extremely helpful and encouraging
because I mean this is this represents
what we perceived as a I I was gonna say
risk but I don't really want to use the
term risk I just feel like it was just a
big decision to share something that's
of
to be vulnerable in this way and to
share these things that no one's begging
us to share and we're not obligated to
share but we just as we've said before
two episodes ago we've already went into
why we are we're talking about it I'm
glad we're doing it like I said it's
been a it's been a long time coming
we've been talking about you know it'll
just come up every month or every couple
of months for many years it's just when
are we gonna when are we gonna talk
about like our the spiritual aspect of
of our lives and and that in our our
faith journey I guess you know knowing
that we always would so yeah okay so
before we get into that I do a couple of
things to acknowledge first of all for
those of you watching the podcast yes I
do have my hair pulled back into some
sort of configuration I don't know the
technical name for this and I apologize
for it if you are the kind of person
like me who judges men who do this with
their hair I would call it a sad
ponytail yeah I think you know what when
your it just seems like it's such an
interesting choice the timing is
interesting because this is such a
momentous I have very specific there's
two very specific reasons why I'm doing
this episode for you yeah I'm doing it
for two reasons link reason number one
is my hair has gotten to the point where
I can do this and then I started
realizing why people do do this because
this podcast I'm gonna be I got notes as
you can see I've got my iPad out I'm
gonna be going through notes I mean I I
don't know where this is gonna go and I
don't want to be distracted by my big
old bouffant falling down in my face and
having to move it all around so it's
just it's tight it's in place and I'm
not gonna think about it now you might
think about it but just stop thinking
about it okay I wasn't even gonna
mention it
thanks the other thing I want to say
real quick is that yesterday link and I
were on the road pitching a project that
we're hoping will become something and
on the way back from now link has been
driving do you want to say that the
project is well yeah we're trying to
turn the loss causes a play Creek into a
TV show so hopefully somebody will agree
to that but we're coming back from a
meeting and the link has been driving
he's got a new fancy electric Aldi and
so he drives everywhere eventually I'll
get a fancy car and then I'll Drive too
but right now we're just enjoying links
new car so he's been driving around town
and then yesterday on the way back from
the other side of town from the West
Side rat at a light and Link just kind
of takes hush when it turns green and
then he turns me he says I almost hit
that pedestrian now first of all you
gotta because you guys didn't you and
Steve you didn't see it almost hit it
because I'm not driving because I mean I
don't have to pay attention to the
pedestrians when you take the I don't
you yeah and you don't have to explain
it you almost always hit pedestrians I
don't know why you're talking about this
but go ahead because last night I got a
message on Instagram what just seen
y'all in the Audi you almost hit me lol
loved the show a fan yeah yeah yeah yeah
I killed a mythical BMO's killed a
mythical beasts oh man oh my gosh so
anyway my gosh he's okay I need to press
these a little shaken up but yeah I'm
not enough to send me and Matt I
wouldn't say a little I'm a lot shaken
up like you do this on a you do this
regularly man okay back to the task at
hand
oh man that's seen it this is when the
spiritual stuff really matters right
right about life and death
exactly okay my goal today first of all
I want to let you know just like link
said today is gonna be different I'm
gonna be doing most of the talking next
week link will be doing most of the
talking and when I say most I mean like
I've got these detailed notes that I've
literally been like making for months at
this point in preparation for telling
this story and so I just don't want to
get things wrong I want to I want to be
able to move through this it gets very
detailed I honestly don't know how
anyone who doesn't come from a similar
background is going to be interested in
what I'm about to say because it kind of
gets into the nitty-gritty of you know
Christian belief and Christian doubt
about those things and my particular
what we call it deconstruction story of
how I no longer consider myself an
evangelical Christian it's very detailed
because it I the thing the things that
were happening
in my mind in my heart is sort of a
particular thread that you may or may
not relate to but it is my story and I'm
gonna tell it like link said I'm nervous
I'm anxious about this I mean the last
two podcasts obviously we were nervous
about talking about those years and how
people might perceive that because
people come from so many different
backgrounds they have so many different
points of view when it comes to this
issue either you're in it you were in it
and you're out of it you're not you two
have no way of relating to it and that
particular perspective that you bring to
you know listening to our stories as
I've seen in these Twitter comments that
people have been making people sometimes
they just don't know what to think about
it you know yeah but the thing that I am
particularly with with telling my story
the thing that I just want to be very
clear about is that I am NOT here to
judge where you're at currently right so
when you tell a story in your lie is to
believe this and now I no longer believe
that and here's why if you still believe
that then you may think there's implicit
judgement and what you think and I want
to say that that is not my intention and
I'm just trying to be as honest about my
own situation as possible and approach
this with as much humility as possible
so that it is gonna get detailed and I'm
trying not really try to condense it
down but this is a this is it like a
years long process this is we're going
back I'm going back basically 20 years
and kind of telling a lot of different
things that happen but I'm gonna this is
not gonna be as detailed as some of you
might want it to be and it's gonna be
more detailed than some of you want it
to be okay so and I'm and I'm I'm here
to support you well thank you link you
wanna hold my own if you need to that
sure I'm also gonna take notes because I
don't want to interrupt you if there's
something I'm thinking that I'll just
jot it down and and if I want you to
hold my hand at any point I will just
extend it okay yeah just do that I'll
know that's what that means
first of all even though we kind of
covered this in one of the previous
guess what it meant to me to be a
Christian now I believed that Jesus was
the son of God that a personal
relationship with him was the only way
to be saved I the only way to go to
heaven when you die and this belief
defined everything for me this this was
of my worldview it gave me purpose and
meaning and I lived with this knowledge
of this spiritual reality right there's
a spiritual reality that is constantly
around us kind of permeating every
decision every relationship every
conversation and I want to emphasize how
big of a deal it was to me it was a
relationship and and I want to say that
because I've noticed that when I tell my
story often people kind of conclude that
I was never a true Christian right and I
and and I'm dressing this up front for a
couple of reasons first of all I
understand what people do this because
this is what I did for many years when I
had friends who said you know I don't
really believe that anymore and I would
be like well you must have never
believed it you must have never really
had a real relationship with Jesus
because according to my particular
theology at the time which was eternal
security which is once you're God's
child you're always God's child and you
can't get away once you have faith you
might fall away for a little bit but
you're always gonna come back and you're
gonna be you're sealed you're delivered
you're gonna be saved and that's a
difficult thing for me now because I
gotta be honest it kind of feels very
dismissive right and I don't think it
really accounts for what actually the
reality was and is and so the only thing
I'm gonna ask is that you just don't
reduce me to a theological footnote as
you're listening to this story because
as far as I'm concerned Jesus was as
real to me as he possibly could be
without physically manifesting himself
in my presence
it was a relationship
you were in conversation so with that
kind of setting the stage I'm gonna get
into the story kind of starting back
with my college years but first we're
gonna do an ad break if that seems like
the most appropriate thing to do well
because we always do ad breaks
I mean it's I'm not gonna apologize for
it it's what makes this possible that's
why we're doing this man I mean it's not
why we're doing this it's how we're
doing this I'm wearing a shirt you can
get it at mythical calm we're drinking
from mugs I think that was a everything
gonna last forever so it may not be
these mugs but it's stuff that you gotta
scoop up when they're at mythical calm
support your boys wrap them up and
unless you unless something about what
Rhett says really makes you never want
to buy anything from us again
yeah then all I can say is I'm sorry
okay I gotta say first of all you
remember okay Dennis Rodman I don't know
I wasn't saying this yes Dennis Rodman
used to have so much energy when he
played for the Bulls that when they took
him out of the game he would go on the
sideline and get on it like exercise but
I remember that yeah
I feel like Dennis Rodman right now you
want to be on a trip I just I just I'm
wired I just I'm just I'm nervous yeah
yeah it's a it's a I want to calm my
breathing when you talk about it for
years
just the two of us when we talk about
this moment for years you might need to
take a breath I'm not got all these
notes I'm freaking nervous cause like
I'm not my story's totally I don't know
I know your story's different that's
what makes it just totally dude that's
what makes a good man we're different
prepared okay this isn't about me go
ahead okay um you're back in the game
get some rebounds
I've always thank you I'm also gonna
marry myself Dennis Rodman jokes for
days okay
I have always been a naturally skeptical
person so even in the midst of a very
vibrant Christian faith I would have
doubts
you know I hear a little something about
how the Bible came together you know how
the 27 books in the New Testament were
kind of put together in the way that you
know the Canon came together and I would
be like this doesn't seem as clean as
maybe I thought that it might have been
I would think a little bit about the
resurrection of Jesus and I'd be like
that's that's that's a tough thing it's
a tough thing but but that's the whole
point it's tough I have faith you know
and what I would typically do is I would
like have these sessions where I would
sort of read arrive my faith but also I
would do what I think a lot of
Christians do is that when you have a
doubt about something you go and you
read a Christian expert you know we call
it apologetics in Christianity somebody
who can basically defend the faith these
are smart people who have who can you
know they can read Hebrew and Greek and
they they've been to seminary they've
written books and they spend their life
studying this stuff and they put out a
lot of material that and they're smarter
than me and they are more knowledgeable
than me so what I would do is I would
just go and I would find somebody who
was smarter than me and they would be
like oh no it's it's very reasonable to
believe this there's very good reason to
believe this and that would kind of
plaster over my doubt in that particular
area for a while what what time frame
are you referring to are you talking
about adulthood are you talking about as
a kid this probably started in high
school was happening a lot in college
and then has happened ever since mm-hmm
but in college I met some people who
were really interested in the book of
Genesis and were specifically what you
call a young earth creationist so this
is someone who believes that the book of
Genesis is literal history and that the
implication from that is that the world
is between six and ten thousand years
old that's when this whole thing began
along with that comes the idea that
Noah's Flood like Noah and the Ark is a
true story and the entire world was
flooded like you know a few thousand
years ago
all the animals were on a boat and then
every single layer of sediment that you
see with all the fossils
and everything in it as a result of that
flood and this there this isn't a small
group of people this is there's a large
group of people in evangelical
Christianity who believe this you still
believe this I never thought about this
my parents didn't really care much about
these particular issues right it wasn't
something that like we grew up being
taught wasn't taught in our youth group
a lot was being taught yeah on a
multiple times a week as we were
involved but we didn't tackle this issue
but it was I was like hmm I haven't
really thought about this let me look
into this and again I'm gonna do this
multiple times in the story today I'm
gonna tell you that I looked into
something and then I'm not going to give
you an exhaustive or extensive there's a
couple places I'm gonna go into that but
here's not one of them because I just
don't have time but long story short
when I looked into this I basically
learned that no matter what scientific
discipline you start from the evidence
points overwhelmingly to a world that is
very old billions of years old to be
specific and basically the world doesn't
really make sense unless it's H ancient
I mean there's so many things about the
world that don't make sense now to just
a couple of helpful books that were
helpful for me there's lots of places
you can see all this stuff but these are
both from a Christian perspective first
one was creation in time by Hugh Ross
which kind of takes a little bit more
look at the astronomical aspect of this
and then another one that gets more into
geology is the Bible rocks and time
which is an incredible resource that if
you're interested in this I suggest that
you read but basically this was learning
that there was all this evidence that
kind of pointed pretty clearly to the
earth being old and then realizing that
there was a really large contingent of
Christians who just denied that and
didn't believe that it was alarming it
was alarming for a couple of reasons I
mean first of all maintaining that young
earth you it requires sort of dismissing
or reinterpreting a lot of evidence that
has been gathered right and you got this
this sort of this big umbrella of
Christianity and the whole idea is
we've got the truth the whole point is
we have the ultimate truth right
as Christians you know God has revealed
the ultimate truth to us this is what I
believed but yet within that camp
there are these two wildly different
perspectives on basically the entire
natural world and I was like something
about this is alarming because this
isn't as clean as I thought it was so I
was unsettled but I was still a
Christian I mean I wasn't the core of my
Christian belief was still very much
intact still believed that the Bible was
completely true and I believe that there
was a pretty easy way to reconcile this
Old Earth view they call it with a
literal interpretation of Genesis in the
Bible and of course I still knew that
evolution wasn't true new evolution
hadn't happened right because that what
I knew is that Adam and Eve had to be
real Adam and Eve had to be real because
so much comes from them being real
that's the fall of that's where the fall
happens and the fall is the reason that
we have original sin and original sin is
why we need a Savior it was like you
can't get rid of that story plus Genesis
presents all this stuff straight from
Adam and Eve and you go through all the
generations even the Gospel of Luke the
genealogy of Jesus features Adam so this
if you don't believe in Adam and Eve
like where do you start believing it
right so I knew that that wasn't I
couldn't let go of that there was
definitely a proof there's a pervading
thought that I had that evolution is
just something you stay away from eat
and if you don't want to get into it
don't get into it just just it's a it's
a problem so don't and it's not right so
don't worry about not even beyond that I
thought evolution just didn't make sense
on its face it seemed completely
illogical in fact it seemed desperate if
you did start to think about it seemed
like it's so it's so non-intuitive to it
was so not intuitive to me at the time
that it just felt like a desperate
attempt
for someone who didn't believe in God to
try to explain the wonderful creation
that we had you got to have something
well if God didn't do it you got to come
up with some rent you got to come up
with something and evolution was the
best thing that they had to offer and
that was it for me and of course I had
read all the books about you know
evolution not being true I was I was
into that in fact I would sit down and I
would argue with people and convince
people who believed in evolution the
evolution didn't happen I loved doing
that you know what I'm saying I can make
people doubt that pretty easily mm-hmm
of course I had never looked at the
evidence revolution I'd I had read books
about it written by people who didn't
believe in it that's what I had done and
I could roll those arguments out with
the best of them then in 2006 I read a
book called the language of God by
Francis Collins now Francis Collins is
currently the head of the National
Institutes of Health he's a geneticist
who headed up the human genome project
when they mapped the human genome there
at the end of the 90s the subtitle of
the book is a scientist presents
evidence for belief this is the kind of
thing that I lived for I loved it when
someone who was a scientific mind who
was respected by the world would come
out and basically do this make it
reasonable to be a Christian to show you
that your faith was reasonable and smart
people believed this I ate this stuff up
so I got into this book I drove right in
now pretty early in the book Collins
starts talking about the undeniable
evidence for evolution evidence that
humans evolved from a common ancestor
with apes you know what will hook will
hold up y'all what this guy's our
Christian what I know that's not true
and of course because he's a geneticist
he's he's focusing on DNA and sort of
that you know the molecular evidence for
this
so one thing that he talked about was
sort of earth-shaking to me this and
this is gonna get technical so please
hold on and that is this idea that the
second chromosome in people is a fused
chromosome so the second chromosome is
fused according to evolutionary theory
we're closely related to great apes and
mostly closely most closely related to
the chimpanzee now all great apes have
24 pairs of chromosomes right but we if
you've ever been at 23andme you know
this we have 23 pairs of chromosomes now
chromosome fusion we're literally like a
pair of chromosomes fuses directly on
top of another pair of chromosomes is
not totally uncommon it happens at about
one in one 1,000 births right you can
result in some issues sometimes but it's
not always the case
so if apes and humans are closely
related like evolution suggests then it
seems that a common ancestor to both
humans and apes had his or her
chromosomes fused together okay so all
right do we see this in the DNA like
what do we see in the DNA well in humans
the second chromosome appears to be a
fusion of two great eight chromosomes
first there are two sections of
chromosome two that correspond directly
to two separate chromosomes in Apes let
me give an analogy if you're having
trouble following this DNA is basically
an instruction manual on how to build
something how to build an organism right
so let's just simplify this and just say
that this book is 24 pages long and
let's say on page two are the
instructions on how to make a hand and
on page three are the instructions on
how to make a foot and so that's what
you see when you look at a chimpanzee
but then when you look at a human you
see that it goes from page two
to page four and there is no page three
but then you look closely at page two
and realize that it's page two and page
three glued on top of each other and you
see the instructions for the hand and
the instructions for the foot on this
long page - does that make sense yeah
that's a simple explanation or a simple
analogy for kind of understanding this
is why our feet and hands are stuck
together exactly in Apes or not again
this is a grossly simple of simplified
analogy but it does help to understand
it now but furthermore there are these
things called telomeres at the end of
chromosomes which basically are these
like redundant material that basically
protects the DNA structure right and so
you would so think of it like you've got
a header and a footer on a page right so
there's always a header and there's
always a footer on a page and if you
were to take two pages and glue them
together in the middle of those two
pages there would be a header and a
footer glued together right if you take
two pages and you glue them on top of
each other like a really long page yeah
a header and footer would be touching
each other well we see two telomeres two
vestigial telomeres directly on top of
each other in the middle of the second
chromosome right so all the evidence is
pointing to these things being fused now
this reason this rock my world so much
is because I was familiar with the
argument that you know almost 99% of our
DNA is the same as chimpanzees uh
everybody knows that because the human
genome has been mapped but the you know
the creationist answer to that is well
yeah I mean God is making he's using the
same building materials to make similar
things it's his prerogative how he does
it so of course you're gonna look at
these this instruction manual and you're
gonna see that yeah it's kind of the
same and then it's sort of different in
some key ways like God it's God's
prerogative why can't he do that but
that doesn't seem like an adequate
explanation to why it definitely feels
like and looks like and seems to be very
conclusive that we actually have the
same chromosomes and they've been fused
that doesn't seem like consistent with
the idea that this is just God
prerogative but that wasn't the only
thing I was so interested in this
particular thing this DNA evidence
because I've heard about the fossils and
all that stuff but this DNA stuff just
seemed this is like how we decide court
cases right and this is this this is how
we can Vic can find out if somebody
actually committed a crime this is
definitive stuff and then I learned
about retroviruses so essentially there
are certain RNA viruses that when you
become infected with them they actually
insert a copy of themselves into your
DNA so you can look at your DNA and you
be like oh you got that virus at that
time and then occasionally these viruses
are that this sort of retrovirus inside
your DNA will be passed down to your
children and that means its endogenous
is in your genes
well we actually see that we share these
endogenous retroviruses with the
organisms that we are closely related to
and the more closely related you are to
them the more retroviruses you have in
common now let me get a gig into take
this this manual this instruction manual
analogy further let's say you look at
page 19 of a chimpanzee manual and you
see oh halfway down on page 19 there is
a coffee stain like somebody spilled
coffee on the manual but it looks like a
copy of a coffee stain like somebody
there was an original and there was a
coffee stain and this seems like a copy
of that like somebody ran it through a
Xerox machine and then you look at a
human instruction manual and on page 18
you see the same exact copy of the same
exact coffee stain in the same exact
place why would God do that you're
thinking and so then you think well it
seems to me that the most logical
conclusion is that these are these two
manuals come from a common manual that
there's an ancient common ancestor that
is the ancestor to both humans and great
apes and this is what you see and these
are just two small pieces of DNA
evidence and I'm not going to go into
any more details but let me just say
that the main thing that this did from
is I had been told a lot of things about
evolution I have been told things
growing up and now I was questioning
those things because I've been told that
there's no there's no real evidence this
is a desperate attempt to try to come up
with some harebrained theory to just
explain things and I'm like but this DNA
stuff is pretty freakin conclusive I
can't imagine another way to know I'm
not saying there aren't explanations for
this I'm not saying you can't go to a
creationist website and find that they
it's not like they don't know about this
they have an answer I've read the answer
I find the answer to not be compelling
in the least but let me just say this
make me just question like all this
stuff you've been told all this stuff
like I had been told that there were no
transitional fossils there were no
transitional forms there's no
transitional between this animal in this
animal well it turns out there's a lot
of them there's a lot of very convincing
ones I've been told that there were
really no vestigial structures that
there's nothing on your body or an
animal's body that's like a sign of
something that's no longer being used
there's always a use for it and we keep
finding those use for it well it turns
out there's lots of examples of
vestigial structures in fact there's
many structures that there's no other
way to properly understand them other
than them being vestigial meaning that
they're from the past they're no longer
in use essentially every criticism of
evolution that I had held on to to
justify my unwillingness to believe in
it turned out to be a misconception or a
misrepresentation of the facts and so
after reading a bunch of books talking
to a lot of people not listen I didn't
want to believe this I'd spent my whole
life not believing this and not wanting
to believe this but I kind of was just
faced with this that evolution was by
far the best explanation for what we
actually see in the real world if you're
interested in any further reading on
this there's a really good wiki entry
called chromosome 2 which breaks this
down with resources it's very well
referenced and there's a wiki entry
called evidence of common descent that
kind of get into this and I'm gonna make
some more wrecks at the end but let me
just say
I didn't want to believe this it was
incredibly problematic and there were
plenty of Christians who I very smart
Christian smarter than me who didn't
believe in it who I could have just I
could have stayed in that camp but I
just in my heart I didn't feel like you
I felt like I had to follow the truth I
thought that my the truth had to be more
important than my commitment to my
beliefs it had to be more important than
my ideology and I and I want to say that
about there's these plenty of Christian
apologists and Christian you know smart
Christian people you I would say just
creationists who deny evolution I don't
think that they're being deliberately
deceptive I want to be clear about that
I don't think these people are saying
releve like oh we see these facts and
we're gonna misrepresent them because
we're gonna lie about this
I think that they're good people but I
think that they're so committed to their
belief system that they have become
impervious to pretty straightforward
information about this subject but the
thing that that did for me is I had
placed a lot of faith not just in God
but in these people who helped me
understand why I believed what I
believed from an intellectual standpoint
right I had a very real emotional
personal spiritual relationship with God
that I was practicing but there was this
intellectual foundation that I would
whenever I had a doubt I would kind of
retreat to this intellectual foundation
and all of a sudden those people I've
been trusting in I began to doubt that I
had been shown the truth or told the
truth about other things right so get to
this answer in due time as you've
planned it but I guess my question is
when you came to grips with evolution
was it just okay now I'm gonna
incorporate that into my face it was
because I know there's people thinking
well you you can understand and accept
the process of evolution and still have
faith I mean well yeah
so exactly you're not an atheist all of
a sudden right which I was very
unsettled but then I was like well hold
up I mean Francis Collins the whole
point of the book yeah is that he
believes in
God because of what he's seen in the DNA
and he's a Christian he's an evangelical
Christian and he believes in evolution
he presented it as that was God's
creative process was involved this stuff
yeah
not to mention you know one of the most
respected and revered philosophical
Christian minds of all time
CS Lewis was a you know was a theistic
evolutionist and so I knew I was in good
company no so I was like this doesn't
mean I'm not a Christian this just means
that I'm a little disappointed in the
way that this subject has been
misrepresented by so many Christians but
again my goal was let's get list let's
stick with the truth all truth is God's
truth I'm not gonna be scared of the
truth God's in control
he's the one who's established this
entire universe I shouldn't be afraid to
poke and pry to any of this stuff right
so that was when I kind of got into this
world theistic evolutionists Christians
there's a good book that I read called
coming to peace with science bridging
the worlds of faith and biology the guy
who believes in evolution but as a
Christian that was a helpful book for me
and then I got really involved or wasn't
involved but I spent a lot of time at
the web site BioLogos which is
essentially a group of Christian
Scientists and there's a bunch of
articles there it's still active I
haven't been there in a long time but I
checked recently it's still there still
doing a lot of things but things get
pretty complicated at this point like
once I started looking into this so I'm
going to give you the short version if
you can believe that that this is the
short version but basically what you run
into is that there's sort of two camps
within people who sort of accept
evolution one camp believes that Adam
and Eve are still real that they are
either a special creation or they're
sort of the result of the process but
there are actually real historical
people because they need to be real and
historical in order for the fall and
then the gospel that kind of makes sense
gotta be honest I did not find all of
those arguments felt
really tenuous and just felt like you
guys are you know that you have to have
you have to have Adam and Eve and so
you're sort of inserting them in in a
way that isn't they're not really
fitting is a little you know square peg
round hole situation
I remember the the Tim Keller book
reason for God you ever discussing that
at that time and that being as I
remember it his position yeah and this
is problematic though because I didn't
basically I was like I just don't think
there's a way that Adam and Eve were
real as presented in the Bible but like
I said earlier you know they're
presented in the Gianna genealogy of
Jesus in the Book of Luke so I what
what's the deal y'all you know I'm
saying this this was this is problem
this is a problem but what this did
again I just felt like this doubt was
kind of creeping beyond the point of
creation and it was creeping into the
Old Testament itself because that's the
way the story goes you got Adam and Eve
and then you got a story that begins
with them and moves all the way down to
Abraham and Moses and then David you
know you you got it's all part of a
system so again I had been told there
was something I've been told about the
Old Testament and that was the Old
Testament is always supported by
archaeological evidence I'd heard that
from so many Christians it's like you
know sometimes they they they see simple
in the Bible and they're well there's no
evidence for that and then they dig a
little bit deeper and they're like oh we
found the evidence or they find that
basically the idea that the Bible is
always vindicated because the Bible is
completely true and everything that it
touches upon but when I really looked
into it
I started realizing that that's not true
that's not really the case just took
just a few things
touching on some quick things why is
there no Egyptian historical record of
the Israelites captivity it's two
million people they kept great records
why are they not where otherwise they're
no record of them why is there no
archaeological evidence of the Exodus
basically this massive group of people
wandering in the wilderness for forty
years they've looked 400 years they've
looked no evidence why does the modern
archaeological evidence call Joshua's
Qwest of canaan into question why is
there good reason to believe that the
Israelites arose not out of conquest or
force but by simply branching off of the
Canaanites and those are just a few
things but there are some pretty major
events that all of a sudden I was like
no this isn't well-supported this isn't
this isn't outside of the Bible these
things are not well supported I was even
further troubled right and so I'm I'm
losing my faith in the Old Testament but
I'm also losing my faith in those same
Christian thinkers who have said all
this stuff that like guys you you this
is solid as a rock you can stake your
entire life on these truths and they're
always be vindicated so I was I was in
crisis at this point but here's but
here's what I said I said does this Old
Testament stuff really matter like is
this really what this is all about isn't
isn't the important thing Jesus right if
this is about a relationship with Jesus
does this Old Testament stuff first of
all okay maybe there's no archaeological
evidence for this stuff maybe there's no
historical evidence of but you can't
really make an argument from nothing
it's like just the absence of evidence
is not necessarily an argument against
something so these things could have
happened we just haven't found that we
haven't found them yet but we can still
have faith and believe them and plus
like I said isn't this just about Jesus
now let me be clear I was still living
in North Carolina at the time I was
still leading a small group Bible study
at my church that I had been leading for
many years and I still consider my still
myself a Christian and I was slowly
letting people that I loved including my
wife and on some of this stuff and every
time I would bring up a piece of it she
would just start crying and just
superimpose that on last week's
conversation in terms of timing from
graduation to being an engineer to being
on staff with crew
so the so where I'm at right now with
this whole like losing losing faith in
the Old Testament and the archaeological
evidence we're probably talking about
like oh nine ten at that point so right
as we're kind of wrapping up it was a
week so this is we had left staff by
this point but the early stuff about
evolution that was oh six right so that
was the year that we that was the year
that we left staff and then a few years
before that I was where I kind of spent
most of my time just thinking about like
the older at the younger stuff I spent a
few years and right five years in that
place again
so at least not not being on staff
there's a little bit of a pressure
release - we owe to be able to at least
start to broach these conversations when
you're when you're in full-time ministry
you have absolutely no impetus to
actually explore these things because
that's your well-being that's your
livelihood a what you why you're gonna
threaten that you don't want to consider
these things because you don't want to
be like if I actually consider this I'm
not gonna end up having to not be a
preacher anymore I'm not gonna have to
drop out of seminary I'm I'm not gonna
stop being a missionary yep or for us
and it's so much stuff for that it was
your full-time job yeah and it was as
we've talked about we were so fully
engaged and committed to working within
those parameters to to pursue our dreams
even not fully understanding that that's
what we were doing
yeah there were subconsciously you don't
want to really engage in anything that's
gonna threaten that but you you couldn't
help yourself I mean it was just your
nature to this concept of truth I think
his I think is the thread and and again
it started like you said in high school
but it brought us to this point so back
to what you're saying you know we had we
had left staff we were making it on our
own you're still very much involved in
the church you're you know you're
teaching people you're having these
conversations with Jessie and she's you
get into a little bit of it and she
breaks down
every time this was this was traumatic
for her every time I would bring it up
and of course I would wait until I it
had become unbearable for me and then I
would bring it up to her because I was
I'm trying to respect her and I would
rate raising these kids and I know how
important this stuff is for her and she
was very educated in all this too you
know we would argue about the
young-earth thing when we when we were
dating in college because that was her
perspective her background and it was
not easy for our marriage and yeah
because you you don't want to bring it
up early because it's but it's nothing
it may pass it's a tough thing to bring
up so it sounds like you start to bring
it up when you like you said just you
can't when I got not bring it up and
then it's almost in a you've reached a
conclusion about something and then
you're spilling your guts to her and
expecting her to she's late to the
process yeah which is actually even more
difficult yeah and you mentioned that
thing about like I the the concern was
with truth and I list I don't know where
this comes from it this is my
disposition my dad was a lawyer and as a
law professor he's you know he's got a
very specific way of kind of getting to
the bottom of things and I think so it's
kind of in my DNA to be concerned about
truth but I think ultimately it was like
again back to what I said at the
beginning is the whole point is that
Jesus is the way the truth and the life
this is the truth you've that you find
the truth the truth sets you free truth
truth truth the whole point of the Bible
about people defend the Bible and say
that the Bible is inerrant without error
it is from God it's it's you know
written by God through people the whole
point of all that is because it being
true is paramount on it maybe more so
than any other faith the holy text being
true is so such a linchpin right now
okay and I just one more that you and
mentioned there were two camps when you
were talking about
that about the Bible being literally
what actually happened versus Adam and
Eve being figurative I don't know if you
were coming back to that or not but it
seemed like again we're at a point where
there's what how you dis describe that's
a certain subset of ya Christian faith
that believes those things about the
Bible yeah and I think it's pretty
fitting that at this point we moved to
California 2011 we moved to California
we immediately got involved in a church
an evangelical church met some great
people made some great friends and this
is when I adopted what I'm going to call
California Christianity to get at what
link was getting out here a second ago
in LA even within the evangelical church
I think there is this sort of because
you're in this incredibly diverse place
with so many different perspectives
you really can't maintain a Christian
faith in a place like this without at
least some sort of realization that
there's a lot of grey it's not about
having it all figured out it's not about
being completely certain it's about a
relationship with Jesus and this was
like a kind of a breath of fresh air for
me honestly coming to California with
all these doubts I found these
Christians who had these doubts
Christians who saw the Bible differently
who were like yeah man I don't know
exactly what happened evolution seems
like it probably did happen and Adam and
Eve might not have been real but like
that's not my day to day with Jesus man
you know and so I have a relationship
with Jesus I wrote in my journal 2011 my
faith is still weak but it is not gone
and possibly God is revealing a
foundation that he can build real faith
upon here are a few things that have hit
me recently from an intellectual
standpoint I may never have certainty
about my faith that pursuit may be
fruitless it's becoming clearer that the
significance of my faith or the so
called proof of Christianity is not
found in a well reasoned argument rather
it rings true the way in
musical note wood it hits my resonant
frequency and that was very reassuring
to me at the time when we moved to LA I
was like man and this kind of crazy
world with people trying to be all about
themselves and this place it's all about
making it an entertainment business I've
got my faith I've got my relationship
with Jesus I've got my Christian
community and I don't have it all
figured out and it is gray but it feels
so true and it proves itself out to be
true in my daily life I tried living
like this I ran into a few problems the
music did not continue to resonate well
in your bosom basically the foundation
of my faith ultimately was still the
Bible even if I had sort of a more
liberal view or more grey view of what
the Bible might mean and represent and
so every time I read the Bible I saw
issues with it every time I heard a
sermon I would have an issue with it my
experience through Christianity was
basically in flaming my doubts and my
questions so the closer I got to it the
more I couldn't quite shake these
questions that continue to linger and
the question the place that I had sort
of put a barrier around and said we're
not going there sure we can talk about
evolution we can talk about the
historicity of the Old Testament but
where I'm not gonna go as I'm not gonna
go to Jesus I'm not gonna question Jesus
but I just couldn't help myself because
I was like my understanding of who Jesus
is is not just based on my experience
with him personally but it's also based
on what the Bible has to say about him
this is why how we know what there is to
know about Jesus and again when I looked
into this my world was rocked in a very
big way I'm not gonna give sufficient
detail here lots of people have gone and
done this who are smarter and more
educated than me but basically there are
just as many views on this as there are
people who study it but essentially I
live my whole life being sure that the
Gospels were historically reliable
almost taking it for granted I mean I'd
read Josh McDowell's evidence that
demands a verdict
and josh mcdowell new evidence that
demands a verdict
I had read least Strobel's case for
Christ I could spit these arguments back
out to you on an airplane and make you
think that well I must be a Christian
why on an airplane by the way because
when you're evangelical Christian you
sit next to a stranger this may be the
only opportunity you ever have to share
the life-changing message of Jesus with
them there were lots of Converse the
conversations that involved airplane
evangelism because it was just like his
captive audience yeah like you're gonna
go this whole flight not saying anything
right what are the crashes now but I
took a second to go one layer deeper and
to look at the answers to the Christian
answers that I had been given all my
life and that was when I realized that
this Jesus thing was very very messy
from a historical standpoint there's a
few books that do a good job of
outlining some of this stuff one of them
is Jesus interrupted by Bar
Erman who's the professor of New
Testament at UNC who incidentally jesse
was in his class and she used to come
home every single day and then we would
come up with ways to go back to argue
against him ironically me and you were
actually involved in a Campus Crusade
initiative on the campus of UNC to kind
of combat what he was doing
because he was having so much influence
on the students so I understood Bart
Ehrman had been the enemy for so long
but what I started to realize is that he
had a very similar story and I thought
that he dealt with the subject matter in
an honest and even-handed way there's
also a book called the historical Jesus
five views which kind of runs the
spectrum runs the gamut on how you can
see this but basically what I just saw
is that there's so many people coming at
this with an intention to uncover the
truth to find the truth and they're
coming to these wildly different
conclusions
this isn't like science you know
somebody does a scientific experiment in
1985 in China and then somebody does the
same scientific experiment in 2019 in
California if they if everything is
controlled are going to come to the same
conclusion
that's not how history works and it
makes it very difficult to come to
definitive conclusions about things but
essentially in the end
by far to me personally the most
compelling and seemingly reasonable view
was that the Gospels appear to be a mix
of religious propaganda as well as
actual history so there's definitely
some history in there I think Jesus was
a real person so does Bart Ehrman but I
don't think that as he is presented
there is completely reliable that's what
I was thinking at the time so what did
you believe about Jesus you reached a
conclusion about the person of Jesus at
that time when you were when you're
researching that I had a picture of
Jesus that was the picture that I had
always had of this person who did these
miracles and died on the cross and rose
again and died for my sins and was God
in the flesh all the things that were
important to believe about him but I had
doubts about those things being true but
I didn't have another picture of Jesus
there was no other picture of Jesus so
you read all these books of you know
this research about Jesus but your
conclusion was not really conclusion at
that point oh yeah I was some process
and so this was incredibly unsettling
right this is this was way more
unsettling than anything that had
happened so far because this was Jesus
this was the core of everything this is
who my relationship was with and all of
a sudden I've got very serious doubts
about about him and I I think that
anyone that you would have conversations
with and you did initiate with not only
Jesse but with me and with other people
that you confided in over over this
decade of going through this if you were
talking to someone who was it was still
very much committed to their faith it
was like much more solid I think the
response maybe it's not spoken is well
yeah as long as you as long as you hold
on to Jesus and you know it's like that
you can't let go of that you can let go
everything else but you can't really let
go of what you believe about Jesus
raising from the dead and and paying the
penalty for your sins instead of you
yeah
either you go to hell or or he does
which he already did and came back right
is the belief so it's you can let other
stuff go and maybe not panic and again
I'll I'll share my perspective on
interacting with you more next week but
I at times that was part of it yeah
because what you believe about Jesus is
paramount but what you believe about
Jesus is still based on what is
presented in the Bible if not where else
are you getting it I mean some people
might be like well I'm getting it
directly from God but that's not what
Christianity teaches it's coming from
God and the Bible and they don't
contradict one another
so when it became clear to me that it
wasn't something that I could have the
same kind of faith in it that I that
I've had I I was I had a meltdown I
didn't do anything crazy externally but
there was a lot happening internally at
this point I said do you remember a time
or a place associated with this well
I've got a couple of journal in another
journal entry that I'd go into which is
sort of the next stage of this thing but
not not particularly but I do remember
saying this at the time I was like God
you are bigger than all of this right I
I'm just this little human who sees
through a glass darkly my I got this
finite mind and I'm trying to understand
the infinite mind the creator of the
universe seems pretty arrogant actually
you know and I was like is God just
sitting there watching me do all this
research and eventually I'm just gonna
going to give me some satisfying answer
and then all I said I'm gonna have faith
that just didn't sink that doesn't seem
like a relationship that's not how you
conduct a relationship I don't make my
wife fit a certain criteria I I don't
ask her a bunch of questions about her
past in order for her to qualify to be
you know I'm saying it's like I
experienced relationship with her on a
personal level and I just felt like I
was just completely in my mind and I
made this whole thing like scientific
and intellectual and also it seemed like
I was being arrogant because I was
waiting for God to fit my expectations I
was creating God in my own image
as opposed to
creating me in His image I had flipped
the script on God and was waiting for
him to like be my little trick pony that
does all the things that I want him to
do in order for me to believe in him
there's a verse that kind of gets in
which was answers basically Isaiah 55
says for my thoughts are not your
thoughts neither are your ways my ways
declares the Lord as the heavens are
higher than the earth so are my ways
higher than your ways and my thoughts
than your thoughts so God saying I'm
bigger than you right
you just there's certain things you just
can't get dude yeah and at this point I
was like okay you know what I think this
is probably where faith comes in you
know it makes sense to me that this
might be where faith comes in because I
am sitting here trying to prove this
stuff out but shouldn't I just have
faith first and then maybe these answers
will be given to me by God isn't this
what faith is all about I mean the whole
point is this it's evidence of things
not seen
right and so your next step was there's
no way for me to know but I'm gonna try
a different route which is I'm gonna
maybe fate needs to come first
yeah and would then we'll open up maybe
that'll lead to something yeah I can
believe in the Jesus that I believe in
because that's what the Bible says I can
believe in the biblical Jesus even
though I have reasons that from
historical perspective to doubt that I
can still believe in it and overcome
that and this is when I ran into some
problems so the first thing was how does
this differentiate me from any other
faith on earth right one of the things
that makes Christian a unique is that
you know it is the way the truth and the
life no man comes to the Father except
through the son right you don't get to
the son through somebody else you don't
get to the Sun through Buddha right but
also evangelical Christians tend to be
pretty critical of other faiths
Mormonism is a perfect example right
if you're in an evangelical church or
certain evangelical churches you know
they teach you that Mormons basically
have it wrong that Mormons Mormonism is
a bastardization of Christianity right
it's not just another Christian group
and they lots of Christians will write
books that explain how all the things
that Mormons believe about Joseph Smith
and these things that happened are not
true and here's why in the Book of
Mormon is not true and here's why so
they can be very critical of that faith
but yet if you say those things to a
Mormon they will say well I have a
burning in the bosom that proves to me
that these things are right so you can
tell me that these things seem wrong and
you can show me certain things but I
believe them to be true and you can't
change that because I have this sort of
seal and sign from God this indication
that this faith is real and this is all
true and I was like isn't that what I'm
doing right now is it I'm now I'm just
saying that I'm just gonna have faith
that things are real damn the evidence
so how does that make me any different
right and ultimately this kind of faith
felt a little cowardly to me to be
honest it felt like what I was saying is
yeah there's some there's some
conclusions that I really don't want to
come to and the way I'm going to avoid
those is just by having faith but
ultimately you just can't make yourself
believe you just can't make yourself
have faith this was a torturous place
for me right and I was there for a very
long time there was lots of praying
there was lots of reading the Bible
which would inflame some of the same
doubts there was lots of talking to
Christians openly about what was
happening I want to be very clear that I
didn't go into a cave somewhere and and
come to these conclusions and never run
them by I didn't want to leave this
thing man I this was my life this was
this defined everything for me this is
this was the foundation of my marriage
this was the foundation the way I was
raising my kids I didn't want it to go
away
it was the orienting purpose-driven
worldview that was what was basically
defined everything about me but yet I'm
having this promise process I'm talking
with people I'm talking to my wife she's
crying talking to me yeah I'm talking to
you I was talking to you the entire time
about this stuff you didn't cry thank
you I didn't cry but the major shift for
me occurred when I asked a question I
never asked I've been very very afraid
to ask this question and that was what
if I'm wrong what if I opened myself up
to the possibility that maybe I have
been wrong about this I want to be clear
I never done that even and all these
things that had like shaken me right all
these doubts that I had I still was sort
of there was this Christian core that
had was completely protected through all
this that I wasn't willing to let go of
but I was like what if what if I am
wrong can I just live like that for a
little bit I'm pretty good at kind of
giving myself over to things right I can
watch a movie and get lost in it I can
read a book I can get lost in it I can
read a book from a different perspective
and I can adopt that perspective for a
little bit to see what it feels like and
I decided that I was going to do that so
like let's just consider what it would
mean if you were wrong what would that
mean about the Bible and when I was
honest with myself the Bible began to
make a lot more sense to me personally
as a product of humans rather than God
it seemed less and less like God's
message to people and more like people's
best guesses about God and in that it
became a lot like any other holy text
and that when I came to that conclusion
or I was and I wasn't fully there I was
just considering what does it feel like
to think this it led to a few more
questions that I'd always been afraid to
ask myself
I'm gonna read these because I wrote
them down these are just a few of the
questions I'd always avoided if I don't
have to believe that God ordered his
chosen people to slaughter men women and
children by the thousands then why would
I if I don't want to believe that every
religious experience of any person who
is not a Christian is ultimately
illegitimate then why would I if I don't
have to believe that anyone who doesn't
have a relationship with Jesus
ie the majority of people who have ever
lived are going to spend eternity being
literally tortured in a fire
experiencing never-ending pain and
suffering then why no pun intended in
the hell would I believe that
and if I can somehow accept the idea
that hell exists because of God's
holiness why would I believe in a God
who would choose to create that
particular world where people have no
choice whether or not they're going to
be born but then once they are born if
they don't adopt the correct
understanding of God he will punish them
forever
why believe in that God if I don't have
to so where did this leave me because
the answer to those questions are that
you have there's a lot of there's a lot
of fear of what you what you might lose
or experience but there are some things
to gain um if you go to the other side
well it's funny because I had spent a
lot of time in my head a bunch of light
intellectual processing of all these
things right philosophical stuff but at
this point as I felt this sort of
traditional faith slipping away I
started worrying about some pretty
practical things like how is my marriage
gonna stay together what am I gonna
teach my kids this is what I've been
teaching them what am I gonna teach them
now what am I gonna do where am I gonna
turn what's gonna replace this this is
this in criticism unit
this is purpose this is meaning where am
I gonna find something like that you
know in a verse came to mind John
chapter six after Jesus has kind of
talked about him being the flesh and
he's kind of basically given the whole
idea of you know communion at this point
and it's a difficult teaching and a lot
of people walk away because they're like
he's talking about eating him and
drinking his blood this dude's nuts and
they it was a difficult teaching people
didn't understand what he was getting at
and they walk away so Jesus asked the
twelve do you want to leave to Simon
Peter replied Lord to whom would we go
you have the words of eternal life we
believe and know that you are the Holy
One of God and that's what I said I was
like listen I got nowhere else to go
what am I gonna what am I gonna become
now let me get clear I was in a state of
panic at this point but I was like I
can't I can't I can't let this I can't
let this go there's two there's just too
many there's too much wrapped up in this
right but this is where being in Los
Angeles did allow me to ask a different
question and let me let me explain that
first of all I have no doubt that many
people will probably not even listen to
this story
in fact I've seen it on Twitter I've
already seen people say you know I don't
want to listen to their personal stories
because I don't want to hear somebody
talk about leaving which that hurts mean
that you don't want to listen to the
story I'm just trying to be honest but I
know a lot of people will come to the
very very easy conclusion guys this is
there's nothing surprising about this
you were Christians and then you went to
Los Angeles and you lost your faith it's
a story as old as Los Angeles this isn't
surprising it's like what's the big
what's the big deal this is super simple
but I'm trying to represent that this
wasn't this wasn't something mate this
wasn't some flippant decision this
wasn't like I
little man I want to be cool and
accepted in modern culture so I'm gonna
shed all this stuff the reason why it
hurts is because it's a dismissal that
assumption is a dismissal
it's an as it's an assumption of your of
your true motives that you don't want to
state which are hey you just want to sow
your Wild Oats and you want or you want
to be cooler you want to you want to be
able to face your friends who believe
different things or like they have
different lifestyles and in order to be
successful out there you got to make
some changes okay I mean watch any award
show now and see how the entertainment
industry is pushing change in
perspectives and changes in the way
people act if not belief and so it's hey
if I get it if you want to if you want
if you guys want to go out there and you
want to pursue your dreams if that's
really what's most important to you then
yeah you got to give up you got to give
up your beliefs I mean you got to make a
choice and it seems like that's the easy
thing you guys made the choice and it
again it's like no one's said that out
loud to us but oh I've seen people say
it they've typed it maybe I've seen it
typed I saw it typed after after our
first two episodes somebody was like
what's the big deal they it's clear what
happened they went to Los Angeles and
they lost their faith it happens and I'm
just trying to first of all hopefully if
you've listened to this point you you
you at least acknowledge that this was a
process that was in many ways
independent of where I was at but also
way more personal and torturous and it
wasn't a calculated business decision it
wasn't like I don't know I that
particular accusation hurts a lot when
people say you were never a Christian
and what people say you changed because
of LA those things hurt a lot because of
how untrue I know them to be so there's
an aspect and I will get into more of it
okay so I think we'll come back to it
but your point for now is
that there was an aspect of you changing
because of la yeah and this is and this
is where la comes into play la did allow
me to ask a new question and that was
why am I still doing this and I'll be
honest I would not have asked that
question if I was in North Carolina
because when you're in the Bible Belt
you're embedded in Christian culture
there are a dozens of reasons why you
would still be doing it I mean why rock
the boat
why disappoint your parents why
disappoint your friends why extra you
know get yourself out of this and
community that you have I would have
been going to the same church
since I was in ninth grade I would say
technically your whole life because that
church came from another church that
right off went to are exactly I've been
with the same group of believers forever
and now I was leading a Bible study I
had preached sermons on Sunday you know
there's an there's all kinds of reasons
not to leave why damage your reputation
because honestly in the Bible Belt this
can be as many people know if you've
left the faith and the Bible Belt it
ain't easy there's a lot of pressure to
stick it stick around and stay in there
but what I realize is that I've been
pulling on this thread for a really long
time right let's call it the sweater of
faith which is not the armor of God this
is just this is this is a real offline
concept the sweater of faith I've been
pulling on this thread and it had sort
of like turned into a vest and then a
midriff and then a halter top and now it
was a string bikini it's not appropriate
and I was like I'm gonna take the bikini
off really not appropriate it's just an
analogy okay
and I wasn't la yeah men in bikini tops
just you know there's lots place you go
to the convenience and I took it off and
I I I call this mean how did you take it
off well I have a journal entry think
right that's great okay give it to me it
has nothing to do with bikinis this is
from 2014 okay
I understand that it is unreasonable to
expect Christianity to be a set of
scientifically verifiable principles it
is a faith implying that some sort of
believing without seeing is involved and
more specifically Christianity is a
relationship with Jesus and
relationships are not well defined or
experienced scientifically however I
don't think it insignificant that the
deeper I have dug into Christianity with
a thirst for the truth the more
difficult it has become to have faith in
fact for me it has become impossible and
that was kind of the reckoning for me
right
that was that was jumping ship to use a
better analogy than taking off a bikini
you see I kind of saw Christianity as
this boat in a very stormy sea its
stable there's a lot of other people on
it it's got a destination you're gonna
get through this
it gives you something to hold on to it
gives you stability it gives you purpose
it gives you direction and it gives you
community and when I jump ship I didn't
jump to another boat I jumped into the
water
and I pulled my wife and my children in
with me I jumped into a sea of
uncertainty and that's where I've lived
for about six years and we're gonna
spend some time talking a little bit
more about where we're at now I do want
to talk about it now but we're getting
more detail and like a subsequent
podcast maybe in a Q&A or something but
I but I I want to kind of talk about
what this has been like without getting
into too much detail and I know because
we're already pretty long this is gonna
be a long one right after I jump ship I
kind of went through a period of anger I
was very mad at the Christian leaders
and thinkers who I felt deceived by
I want to be very clear about this no
one that I was in personal contact with
pastors Christian friends elders in my
church
none of them disappointed me or let me
down I did not have a personal like
tragedy a lot of people have like a
traumatic spiritual experience in a
church I didn't I only got good things
from the church we talked about this
while back that like listen I'm a
straight white dude you know you get a
lot of things handed to you especially
within the church if you fit that
profile in some churches being a
straight dude is the only way that you
can teach there's plenty of churches
right now churches in Los Angeles that
people would consider progressive where
you better not tell them you're gay and
if you're a woman you probably won't be
able to preach its 2020 and this is
still the case I just want to be clear
about that but but for me this had been
I got so much out of this I was riding
high I could have ridden this train to
the top man you know I'm saying but and
nobody disappointed me personally but I
was angry at the thinker's I was angry
at the people who had written the book
saying that evolution didn't have any
evidence I was angry at the people who
had written systematic theology books
who basically made it seem like this was
all pretty simple and I kind of the
pendulum swung for him for a time into
atheism I was like this is all [ __ ]
and I'm gonna be the enemy of this stuff
I'm gonna be an anti evangelist that's
what I was thinking at the time of
course we're still very private about
all this so it wasn't like I said this
to anybody publicly and that anger
actually subsided rather quickly it's
interesting I kind of had my moment of
anger in atheism and then that was
replaced with kind of an openness and a
curiosity you know it's interesting how
liberating this one aspect has been
I think the biggest change that has
happened to me in my life is that I've
lost my appetite for certainty
specifically certainty about things I
don't think you can be certain about
I think Christianity my struggle with
Christianity for me a big part of it was
I had to keep aligning my thoughts and
being certain and kind of reader iving
my faith and why this was reasonable and
being sure about this and knowing
exactly what was gonna happen when I
died and all this stuff but when I was
like I don't think I can be certain
about these things it's like when a
person I've heard this happens I haven't
done it yet when you stop eating meat
you lose your appetite for meat a lot of
people say I stop being certain about
things I lost my appetite to be certain
I didn't wake up with a sense of panic I
thought there would be panic I thought
there would be chaos especially for
someone who that's how you lived your
life and I thought there would be few
and so attached to it right but it's
been the most liberating thing that has
happened in my adult life I'm not
kidding I'm not trying to paint that
listen it's not like I'm about to give
you some philosophy that I live
according to now that's got did the
gives that gives me community purpose
and meaning I don't have that okay I
think there's a giant sort of shift
that's happening culturally and I think
that we may be arriving at that some
time but it doesn't exist right now for
me but what does exist is an openness is
this curiosity listen I still think that
belief in God is very reasonable I think
that the idea that the universe is
ultimately purposeful it's headed
towards some ultimate purpose not only
is that comforting but it kind of feels
again it feels right to me when I just
look at the the history of the world and
we're you know but I don't know it to be
certain and I don't know anything about
this source or this god that might be
behind all this and I'm kind of
beginning to think that I don't know if
you are supposed to know a whole lot
about it
so I would call myself a hopeful
agnostic meaning I don't know about I
hope I hope there's something in a
question that I've gotten from some
people who are close to me love me
is what do you think happens after you
die I don't know I'm reasonably certain
that you don't burn in hell because you
were intellectually curious and honest
to put it bluntly but honestly I'm more
interested now and what happens while I
live it's not so much what happens after
you die but what happens while you're
alive and I'm trying to answer that
question but it's one of the reasons I'm
in therapy it's honestly one of the
reasons that I get up every morning and
do 20 minutes of back exercises honestly
it's one of the reasons that I think
more about what I eat because the only
thing I know that I've got is this life
you know but the other thing that has
kind of happened because people ask me
about you know your marriage your kids
will get into this in more detail but
jesse has her own story there's been a
lot of crying but she's in a similar
place now and this process because we
were so know this this this whole
process ruins a lot of marriages I've
seen it a lot because sometimes people
are like I can't go they're not going
there it's over
this was the whole foundation I mean
yeah we made vows if you read we wrote
our own vows for our wedding and they
were very much about Jesus Jesus but now
it's kind of like our marriage has hit a
second wind where it's not so much about
a structure that we both sort of assent
to that tells us what our marriage
should be like but it's like hey it's
pretty cool that I get to go through
life with you I love you and that has
actually been pretty a pretty good thing
to concentrate on and with the kids you
know I think
for me the idea that the purpose and
meaning and sort of like orienting your
life in a certain way all came from the
Bible and from church I actually because
none of that went away you know I'm
saying like I still have a I still have
I still want to be the same kind of
person that I've always wanted to be I
want to be the same kind of husband I
want my I want the best for my kids
I mean meaning like your morality yeah
like you yeah you don't the moment that
you jumped ship you didn't start looking
to cheat on your wife right as an
example
exactly it wasn't like all of a sudden
cuz I mean I'd always been told that and
I had many Christians who I respected
said man if God wasn't real I would be
out doing drugs right now I'd be out
sleeping with whoever I want I'm like I
don't actually think you would I don't I
think you actually have an innate desire
to be a pretty good person and to live a
life that is good for you and the people
you love and a lot of people will attach
it to a structure and an explanation
like Christianity but I think very few
people actually find the purpose in
their faith I think they have purpose
and then they bolster it with faith
that's my personal opinion
or even another way to put it using the
like the marriage example do you think
that your your motive to be true to
Jesse was not just out of love for her
but out of love for God you know out of
respect for you know so now you're you
being true to Jesse is out of love for
her it's a line like I'm yeah and it's
not it's not a fear of God it's a feat
it's a love for her and it's a fear of
listen there's a lot of [ __ ] that
happens when you do stuff like that in
your life there there are natural
built-in consequences to doing the
things that are traditionally considered
too
be sinful according to every religious
tradition it's not like you just if I
didn't have this I'd be out doing all
kinds of crazy [ __ ] no you wouldn't
it's like first of all my best friends
now are not Christians but they're
faithful to their families and they're
not horrible they're not horrible and I
think that's what we thought was without
without the Holy Spirit indwelling you
you're I mean you're you're just going
off the flesh so to speak you're going
off of your own desires and you I mean
that's the only thing keeping you from
being a horrible person I think that's
from a young age I think that's what we
felt but I think the thing you recipe
that's a particular view of people that
we had in our particular light reformed
you know Calvinistic mm-hm everyone is
totally yeah raved in ain't anything
good that is coming from anybody is
either because of their it created an
image of God or they have a relationship
with God III think too I want to get
back to like that being a subsection and
everything that you've talked about
being applied to the whole of
Christianity or faith or anything like
that but before that you were talking
about you were moving to the kids from
your relationship with Jesse I kind of
went back to the relationship with Jesse
so when you're talking about the kids
you were talking about raising them in a
way to be to be whole people to be to be
to be good people I don't know I don't
put words in your mouth but I think you
were getting it well I think the biggest
thing the biggest thing about kids is
what I have sort of observed and being
very much embedded in the church for a
very long time is there's kind of this
idea that it is your responsibility as
parents to make sure your kids turn out
all right and that it's up to you you
better teaching the right thing if you
don't they're going to be screwed up and
I'm not saying that you shouldn't teach
your kids good things but what I've
observed is that you know what my kids
actually teach me a lot I think that
kids I think that kids orient themselves
in the world much more readily based on
your behavior than the specific things
that you tell them I don't think that
having an information session with your
kids and doctrine aiding them it's
what's going to make them into a good
person I'm not saying we're not
constantly talking about issues of moral
morality and ethical things
philosophical things and we talk about
that every time our family is like very
much always talking about these things
but the interesting the sort of freeing
thing is is that when my kids have a
question about God or the deeper purpose
of the universe or what happens when you
die
we explore those things as people I'm
not here as some authority that's gonna
point you to this ironclad thing and
that's gonna make it okay because you
know what it's not gonna make it okay
just because I can point to this book
and tell you that you should believe
this I'm I am proof that believing those
things isn't necessarily going to make
all those deeper thoughts go away and so
in getting my kids comfortable with sort
of living intention and live it being
okay with not having all that stuff
figured out but it's like well what can
you have figured out and what does lead
to a fruitful meaningful life well you
know what a life devoted to others a
life devoted to yourself is going to
fail I can't explain I don't feel like I
have to explain the dynamics behind that
for it to be true and so but you do
explain it sometimes you talk about
being a parent as if like just you are
you gonna be and I know that's not what
you're saying but I think what you just
said is clarifying that you are your t I
am saying that to an extent I know you
are I am saying that we have a little
bit of a difference well I think right
but I would say that the latest child
psychology basically suggests that kids
sort of they're gonna be a certain way
but but you're talking about so
selfishness versus self-sacrifice you
talk about what it means to love you're
talking about who what type of person do
you want to be yeah and what and also
the thing I try to get my kids to do is
process the consequences of their
actions it's just like hey Shepherd if
you I just asked you if you had mom's
phone and you told me no but you do have
mom's phone let's talk about why you did
that and let's talk about what it means
to be a person who's willing to lie
who's willing to say something that's
false about this and what do you and so
it's like what is going to happen if you
become a person who can't be trusted
what's that gonna do what kind of life
are you gonna live as a person who can't
be trusted
and and for me that just is a that
tangible like nitty gritty getting down
to the details of like what does this
mean where the ramifications of your
behavior for me it's in listen listen I
know that I've read all the Ravi
Zacharias books and I've seen him speak
I know that the whole idea is well
where's the morality come from if it's
not coming from a moral lawgiver God
himself I think that that argument is
marginally compelling but I don't think
it's I don't think that is conclusive
and I and I I think the point is is I
don't think you wake up and make
decisions to be a good person because
you've got this moral lawgiver there may
be a moral lawgiver I'm not saying that
God doesn't exist but I'm but I think
that it's a much more natural and
organic process than there's a book I
read it and now I know what to do I
think that's why those core qualities of
what makes a human good exist in
cultures everywhere you find a culture
in the middle of the Amazon that's never
been exposed to the gospel or any sort
of religious system outside of what they
believe but they're gonna think that
murdering is great probably not they
didn't need Hammurabi Hemi rabbi or you
know Moses to tell them that
so but I guess I'll move on and one
other thing whatever his name is I don't
think that's how you say his name him a
Robby's coat
I was curious personal question when it
comes to therapy does anything to come
up I know you talked about anger and you
also talked about how it wasn't there
wasn't an inciting incident outside of
your own intellectual exercise and
research but do you find that there's
that there that there's that there's
baggage that there's things that you
need you know things that you need to
heal from maybe that's a or now that
your perspective is shifted is there any
of that you know again and I feel I kind
of feel like an [ __ ] for saying this
because I know that so many people so
many women and so many people who don't
fit the mold and we talked about like
the LGBT q+ experience of people in the
church a lot of there's a lot of stories
of trauma because as people were sort of
developing their identity and self
actualizing they're doing it in an
oppressive environment and that's
damaging but again because of who I am
and what I look like I pretty much just
benefited and so I don't look back at my
experience with the church in a
traumatic way I just feel like man I
just I was very lucky and I got and I
actually we talked about it last week I
got professionally I got a lot out of it
I was able to develop professionally and
do and live my dream out for me
most of my therapy is related to you
know just sort of the realization that
everyone's personality is essentially
construct
over their child that their inner child
and it's a way of sort of navigating and
moving through the world it's a
protective shell and so for me it's like
why is that your shell and what is that
child underneath saying feeling do you
sort your early childhood stuff and it's
not trauma it's just figuring out but do
you feel like everything that you having
constructed that shell that we the
belief system that you had was a was a
became a part of that became another
layer
I haven't processed it but but
definitely yes I haven't gotten today I
have got again an area again it's like
the thing that you're taught your whole
story is so much in your head you know
it's like when you talk about well yeah
you'd be devastated and like those
moments of there's being a crack in the
in the dam and then when when you decide
to jump ship like I mean you allude to
it being a torturous time he said that
there's moments of like being really
scary mm-hmm but it does seem like the
story is very much in your head you know
there yeah yeah in in so maybe there's
stuff under there and I understand
that's one of the reasons that a lot of
people won't relate to what I'm saying
because they're like why is this I've
just Christians that I know and love who
when I talk to my telling this story I
just kind of see them just look off and
quit listening cuz it's just like wow
he's he's spending all this time talking
about the second chromosome right like
why is that important to him and what
does that have to do with God
yeah and for me it has everything to do
with my story because it's all related
you know again the whole idea is that
this foundation is truth and so but in
terms of I I feel like my attempts to
like focus on the relationship and focus
on faith was my attempt to get out of my
own head and get into my heart when it
came to my perspective on God mm-hmm
and to lean into the relationship but
again it's the it's that
inextricable relationship between facts
and feelings you know I it's it's still
you can have an incredible experience
with somebody relationally and it can
feel completely emotional and physical
but yet there is sort of a scientific
representation a naturalist
understanding of what's happening
between the two of you and I think that
there's this foundation that I just kept
coming back to and every time I came
back to it an interesting thing is it
isn't like the Christian apologists are
saying that they don't make the argument
that I was trying to make them ahead
they don't say don't worry about this
just have faith they say because they
know they have to know this is
defensible here's why here's why
evolution didn't happen and here's why
you can trust and I can even prove to
you I know a guy who wrote a term paper
in college on why the resurrection is an
undeniable historical fact those things
being true are sort of what the founding
fathers of the faith you know especially
those guys in the early church you were
like figuring out how to think about all
this stuff they were doing intellectual
work it wasn't just happening in the
heart they were laying a philosophical
framework that we've built our faith on
and I think that we've got more access
to information about that process than
we've ever had and it deserves some
scrutiny and I actually think it doesn't
stand up to scrutiny that's my personal
opinion I could be wrong but that's that
that's where that's why on that so two
things I want to come back I want to end
on like your label that you apply to
yourself but I did want to ask how do
you process the anticipated criticism of
everything you shared I mean III don't
know
yeah I know I I am I'm a three on the
iniya gram and one of the
characteristics of a three which is an
achiever is you want to be liked by
everybody and being misunderstood or
misrepresented is a direct assault on my
ego and I know that that's going to
happen but it's just part of the growth
process being okay with it being okay
with people mischaracterizing the things
that I've said people dismissing the
things that I said obviously there's
gonna be a lot of people who say that
oh well it's clear he was never a
Christian he didn't really he had an
intellectual understanding but he was
never in relationship with Jesus because
he couldn't have been doesn't it's not
consistent with my theology that that's
again I like I said that's tough but I
think it's only tough because I'm an
egotistical [ __ ] sometimes I think if
I'm truly humble then I then I shouldn't
I shouldn't let those things bother me
you know it's just like yeah that's
gonna happen but I don't know I don't
know how I'm gonna process it I don't I
actually I've seen that you've engaged a
little bit with people on Twitter and
for some reason I just haven't I just
haven't had the emotional energy I've
been thinking a lot about this story I
think I will engage with people if they
have questions I think we will engage
with people if they have questions and
you know after you tell your story which
I'm excited to hear your story because
you're so different than me you know and
I think this type of in this this
experience and I think but it's very
much intertwined and I think it's you
know we made a decision for you to go
first and I think that's gonna be that's
very helpful for me for people to
understand my story second yeah but go
ahead I mean I don't know I I don't know
how I'm I'm definitely because I want
everybody to like me which is a flaw
it's not something I'm proud of
um I know that some people won't like
this a lot of people won't like this
a lot of people are gonna be offended a
lot of people are gonna say that I
misrepresented the facts a lot of people
are gonna say because listen if you if
you agree with everything I said then
you know how could you still have faith
so it's like I understand that I
remember we had we had a good friend we
had a good friend who had a bunch of
doubts and I remember how we treated him
and I loved him but I remember when he
started talking all this stuff about how
he was doubting certain things I was
like I remember asking I was like what
are you gonna teach your kids man I do I
remember that and I remember thinking
things like man I guess he just I guess
he never I guess he never knew Jesus
because the Jesus I know I would never
think those things and I know that's how
I know how I would have processed
hearing this story in it again it just
has a sidenote
difficult I mean I'm glad that we still
have a relationship with him and that
we've talked through it since then and
that he was he was patient with us in a
way that now we're asking for people to
be you're asking people to patient with
you and I'm asking for people to be
patient with me yeah patient not in
waiting for someone to change their mind
but just to to be just to still be
loving he was still very loving to us
even though it had to have been written
all over every everything we said and
every our faces you know yeah for sure
do you we should wrap things up okay so
I think my my last in a desire to put a
bow on something are you happy with the
label that you've given yourself of
hopeful agnostic I mean is is that are
you happy with that I don't know how to
answer I mean you just who it's just
where I'm at I am I am happy I am happy
I did a destination I guess is for me I
am open
to revelation from God like I haven't
lot it's like listen there's some things
I step back there's some things that I
am I don't think I'll ever believe again
like I'm not ever gonna believe that the
earth is ten thousand years old like
that that car left the garage a long
time ago I don't think I can have a
worldview that doesn't embrace the
reality of evolution that every living
being on the earth is related to every
living being on the earth and I actually
think that's beautiful even from the
perspective of there might be a creator
and I know that I could go into the
desert or I can go into the office and
have a crazy religious experience that
all of a sudden I come back and I'm like
I got I got something for you and I'm
not closing myself off to that I'm not
I'm not some pure Naturalist because
listen if anything that if I restore
represents anything is that I'm willing
to change my mind I had a faith that was
so solid
I had this was so deep this wasn't the
Sunday morning thing man this was a
lifestyle this was in my blood and I let
it go because I did not believe it to be
true
I'm gonna follow truth wherever it leads
without fear without fear of
uncomfortable conclusions and if that
means that oh and you know what you're
gonna have an encounter with God that is
going to send you to some new place or
send you all the way back then so be it
but the thing I don't want to do is I
don't want to I feel like the curiosity
and the openness that characterizes in
my life right now it's something I don't
want to let go of and I don't want to be
in fact quote from Ravi Zacharias that I
used to say I'm gonna butcher the quote
but he essentially talked about you know
being you don't want to be so
open-minded that here mind is like a
sewer just letting everything in you
know you eventually you got to bite down
on something so I recognize that you
just can't be passive but actually I
don't know I have had some experiences
and come to some conclusions but I'm not
ready to share all that at this point
but I would say that if anything it's oh
it's just sort of confirmed the
direction that I've been going kind of
away from the faith of my childhood
that's my story thank you for sharing
I do have Rex make a wreck and then tell
me it feels good to get it out uh first
of all it does feel good to tell his
story you have to wait a little bit yeah
I'm gonna sleep well tonight link I
didn't sleep well last night my I've
already mentioned a couple of these
wrecks but I'm gonna say it again
because they relate to what I just told
you about again the wiki entry on
chromosome to read it it's a short one
is super easy to understand it's a
better explanation of what I just said
the wiki entry entitled evidence of
common descent which is a long one again
the people might be like why are you
pointing people to Wikipedia well
Wikipedia is actually a great reference
for these kinds of things because it's
footnoted in referenced and you can go
to those resources if you want to dig
deeper but it's a great comprehensive
up-to-date list sort of a living list of
the evidence for evolution but if you
are a book person whether you want to
read or listen to it I do recommend why
evolution is true by Jerry Coyne which
is a pretty sort of easy to read
explanation if you've never kind of dug
into the subject and and was you know I
was already on that train when I read
that book but it's I just thought he did
a great job of putting it together
so those are my wrecks thanks for
listening to this long podcast hopefully
link will go even longer
we'll see has tagged your biscuits
thanks for being a part of the
conversation and for hearing us out well
we'll speak at you next week to watch
more ear biscuits click on the playlist
on the right to watch the previous
episode of your biscuits click on the
playlist to the left and don't forget to
click on the circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms thanks for being your
mythical best